[Music]
all right so thanks very much for the
introduction what we wanted to start the
panel talking about was basically the
giving you guys a bit of insight into
the path whereby new researchers are
finding their way into this field and
into thinking about these questions so
I'm gonna ask each of the panelists to
go through and basically tell us a
little bit of their story that that sort
of brought them up here onto this stage
so in particular can you guys talk to us
about what's the path that you took to
this field what were you doing before
you decided to start doing research in
this area what motivated you to come
into this area and what were the
concerns that you had as you considered
this as a research endeavor so with that
al-mahdi if you are okay yeah okay so
I'm a second year PhD student at
Berkeley right now but I also did my
undergrad at Berkeley so in 2015 I guess
I was a second year undergrad and I
happen to live in this big house where
one of my friends in the house started
this class on effective altruism at
Berkeley so I would like occasionally
show up and like one day they were
talking about existential risk and may I
risk and it was my first time I ever
heard of this so naturally I thought it
was crazy and I got into a debate with
some people there and I don't think they
made that great of arguments in the
moment but people kept deferring me to
this book they were like oh but like
heavy read superintelligence and so I
was like all right let me go like check
this out see what it is and so I read
superintelligence and then I was like
okay like I get the abstract argument
like maybe I don't agree with the pots
or whatever but like I got what they're
saying but that still sort of stayed in
like the back of my head is kind of
interesting but sci-fi II until the next
year in 2016 I took this class on human
compatible AI that was taught by Stuart
Russell along Catterick on Tom Griffiths
I think Jaime was in it and
you're in a to Dylan and that was the
first time I saw like oh there's
actually like real research you can do
on this concrete things like in
particular I think one thing Stewart
said in like the first or second day
really stood out to me it was like we
always assume we have this reward
function but like where does the reward
function come from god and I was like oh
my god this is what is God what is the
reward function and then I got really
interested in the like actual problems
that got really interested in value
alignment and it just seemed like it was
really fascinating like an area that was
really new and had these like really
high-level vague notions but there's
just a lot of interesting conceptual
work to be done you know more so than
like if I was working on something else
like I could work on like improving
bounds on bandit Bagh rhythms or
something but like this was just more
fascinating interesting to me and so
then that summer was when chai started
and that's kind of how it got into it
but I kind of like the thing I want to
highlight from the story is although I
first heard about this through like the
effective altruism irrationalist II
communities the thing that actually got
me into it was the academic opportunity
to work on it so I think the academic
legitimization of the field has been
really important and like concretization
to real things great
thanks but the money if you want to go
next yeah I are I've from physics like
graduated in physics back in 2011 I
worked I worked for four years at least
and I worked first in physics research
as an engineer and then I started a
science YouTube channel in Morocco and
so I was doing a lot of science
communication and tutoring material like
Khan Academy style and then yeah
eventually it's become an EP FL projects
in French in English but that that
period got me exposed to to CS to
computer science computing in general as
a fundamental science of which I was not
aware of and I think this is a problem
in the Natural Sciences community in the
Social Sciences community and as well in
the cs community people in CS including
top researchers are not aware that this
field computing started as a natural
science like the most cited paper of
Alan Turing is on morphogenesis so I
started I got so I started PhD with this
motivation let's make comp
science and natural science again and
yeah my topic was to study robustness of
biological processes which is still half
of my job
and at some point looked at ml machine
on in and say yeah like I mean it's
tribute to the computing group they do a
lot of robustness research let's just
like mix up the 30 years perspective of
distributed computing robustness into
machine learning and somehow I got into
the the busing of AI safety research
I'll just say like as an aspiring
natural natural philosopher which I
still aspire to be I'd like to try and
to make a career under the slogan boast
from in the trenches so there was this
there was this rant against Nick's book
by some famous AI researcher saying that
we down there in the trenches of AI
research and then got into renting
against Nick's book I think it's a very
good thing that we have a generation of
both drones in the trenches people who
think like a natural philosopher and who
are close to boring stuff like convex
optimization and stochastic gradient
descent I'll say I think convex
optimization is super exciting it's well
taken all right how many you go next
great so I came to this field from the
from the origins of control theory and
engineering and really I've been
interested in safety for a very long
time it's just I started looking at this
kind of safety only more recently and my
earlier work had to do with well we're
building increasingly complex systems
many of which are automated and they're
starting to go from very controlled
environments and factory floors to
really more deployed systems like cell
driving cars and drones and these
systems are having to interact with an
increasingly complicated world and most
importantly they're starting to interact
with people and so how can we extend the
guarantees that we that we are more or
less comfortable with writing for
systems that operate inside of a cage to
systems that are no longer in a cage and
systems that are actually interacting
with very squishy and and wobbly things
called humor
that we can very rarely say anything
specific or you know clear-cut about and
so that was the the the motivation that
took me to Berkeley to start my PhD in
robotics and control theory trying to
extend safety guarantees to more
complicated systems that also interacted
with humans and through this path I
started looking more into well how do we
model human cognition how do we figure
out what humans are up to and what
they're trying to do and through this I
started interacting with Tom Griffiths
first who's a professor in cognitive
science and then with anchor dragon once
she joined Berkeley and we started
thinking a lot about the connection
between safety guarantees for systems
that have to operate with humans but
also having a better model of what
humans are up to and what they're trying
to do and through this I got exposed to
problems like value alignment and
through the class at Smith I mentioned
where some of us were there and we were
having you know reading papers and
having discussions about the different
aspects of you know and safety
considerations for AI systems I started
to get a bit of you know a longer-term
perspective where you realize that yes
these systems become increasingly
capable and they start to interact with
an increasingly complicated world it's
going to become more and more difficult
to analyze them or to to ride easy
guarantees about how they're going to
behave and so I think that was the the
angle that that motivated me to start
looking at the longer term problems and
I think some of the you know some of the
concerns that you have there is well it
seems and perhaps we will talk about
this a little bit more later it seems
that some of these fronts are very vague
by construction because we're talking it
we're trying to give guarantees about
technologies that are not quite here yet
and there's a lot of unknowns about what
they're going to be like so I think
going from the you know coming from the
perspective of safety guarantees where
you're always trying to give very
specific to make very specific
statements about your systems and what
their structure is going to be how
they're going to be constructed and
projecting those forward in time to
technologies that we
a lot of uncertainty about it's one of
the one of the you know big challenges
that you face when you're trying to to
enter this field right thanks at me and
finish it up so I came into this field I
think first from the perspective of like
effective altruism and like wanting to
like do something that would be useful
for like the long-term future so I think
it was like five or six years ago at the
end of my undergraduate degree I was
like wanting vaguely to do like
something that was like useful with my
like computer science education and I
started like googling and then ran
across this research area and started
reading about it
and we sort of like just read about it
and like digested it became fascinated
about the the like problem of AGI but it
took you know like a bit of time to like
digest that and also for I think to like
get some more like clarity around like
what the arguments were and how they
related to like current machine learning
so the things like super intelligence
and like the concrete problems paper and
some of the like early sort of like
machine learning concrete implementation
like let's look at this problem in like
a concrete system kind of work came out
and then it was fortunate enough to get
an opportunity to do an internship with
Owen Evans at the future of humanity
Institute and work on a like technical
AI safety paper that was in like the the
context of like Atari reinforcement
learning systems but like trying to like
build something that could learn like
that could sort of like learn
constraints to like keep an agent from
doing something that was like
catastrophic during the training
procedure and like I think this yeah
like from there I ended up applying to
the University of Toronto and being
started working with Archer gross and
was very was lucky to like find a place
where there were were there like several
professors now
who are actually at this conference and
are interested in the concept of AGI and
looking at things from that perspective
so in terms of things about I like what
I was worrying about when applying to
the program it was sort of like is this
like is this something that like I think
I started off being like is this
something that I can like actually
contribute to this all seems like very
vague and abstract and like difficult
like conceptual work and then seeing
some of the like concrete research that
was done sort of helped with that and
then I guess just like whether I could I
would be able to like go into somewhere
like academia and be able to work on
problems that were like motivated by AGI
and be like you know yes this is like my
motivation that I'm like thinking about
these systems that like we don't have
today whether that would like be
accepted or like perceived to something
weird great so I think one of the things
that really came out for us in
discussions in preparing for this panel
and seeing what we really wanted to
share was that we all feel like we've
had some interesting experiences of what
it's like being a student in this area
and we've talked with a lot of people
about the importance of attracting new
talent and new researchers and thinking
about what we're going to be you know
where does the next generation of AI
safety researchers come from and so to
that end I thought it would be great to
get some examples from the panelists of
basically challenges that you faced in
this area and also the benefits that you
faced from being here what have you
found from working on this problem that
has been positive for you and your
experience so maybe we'll reverse the
order from the previous one and we'll
start with William on that one so I
think in terms of challenges that I
faced I think one big challenge is that
like again the the front of trying to
look at sort of the long-term of like
systems that don't exist and also like
being in sort of like a field that's at
an early stage of development where like
we sort of don't have like the amnesty
of AI safety like the problem that's
like the concrete and well-defined and
we know that if we like do really well
on this problem that like we would have
like solved like AI safety
something I'm it feels like I'm more at
the stage where I have to figure out
like what are the problems that we could
solve and and like defining those and it
also is you know feels like I didn't
sort of like come in and like you know
have like you know find find a professor
who was like this was a here's this like
concrete research project to start out
it feels like sort of like we're all in
kind of the same boat of like trying to
like defy in the field and so like yeah
figuring out how to define things and
then like also like being confident that
like their research that I'm doing is
like useful rather than just going off
in like some weird direction has been a
challenge I think in terms of yeah like
things that have helped me are like
being able to work with the sort of part
of the a safety community that's not
within academia or like not in like the
traditional academic setup so for
example for my research now that's
trying to look at iterative
amplification I've been like
collaborating with researchers a lot
with like andreas to Muller and trying
to get some you know having some like
direction from like that part of the
field in like shaping my research to be
like useful to them and being able to
learn from their perspectives so yeah I
think and this is probably something
that essentially all of us have in
common but definitely the fact that the
questions that we're trying to answer
are often you know sort of high level
and at the beginning feel a little bit
vague because there are so much
uncertainty around the you know the
systems that we're trying to prove
properties about and I think that it's
it's it's important and for me it was a
bit of a chance to reconcile the kind of
work that you've been doing so far and
the sort of philosophy of your own
research that you're trying to maintain
with the fact that you're now trying to
apply it to a field that it's very much
in its early stages and where you are
way trying where you're trying to make
statements about something that is still
in a very in a very fuzzy state and I
think that
this also there's also projects onto
something that I think needs to start
happening a little bit more consistently
which is in general we as a field to to
gain academic legitimacy we need to
start lots of stuff that's not fair we
need to focus more on providing concrete
and tangible solutions to problems and
speculation is this course necessary and
it's important given that we are at a
very early stage but it it can't be a
substitute for concrete results concrete
solutions theoretical results I think
are best at this stage and they need to
be general enough that they will admit
you know the variation that that we
still don't know about in that and that
you know well we will sort of gradually
discover as we move forward into the
future but they can't be too generic and
you know to the extent of being trivial
statements or essentially not useful
ones so I think that was a struggle that
I had at the beginning sort of trying to
focus not only on concrete problems but
concrete solutions that I could give to
those problems I think we've done a
fairly fairly ok job I think it's a as
the technical side of the field at
defining concrete problems but I think
the solutions also need to become creed
and that sometimes there's a bit of a
challenge and personally I found that
having the try group emerged at Berkeley
was very useful because in it gave me
the ability to start grounding my my
thoughts and bouncing my ideas off of
other people who were also thinking
critically about these sorts of problems
and that was a very useful thing to have
although I also have to say on the other
hand I think a good thing that China has
is that every person who is a member of
chai is also really a member of some
other lab that it's doing technical
research on other aspects of the field
and I think keeping our work grounded in
the field of AI robotics control theory
is also important and really is
something that hopefully will help
establish a geotechnical ági safety as a
as a field of engineering
great almani okay so yeah I was just
like I want to I know that the fact that
in terms of challenges we remain a lucky
generation compared to maybe Stuart's
generation or people before us if I
really should be easy sorry Stuart yeah
thank you thank you for making it easy
fun yeah so we have like for example you
can be like out of the field not even in
ml and stumble open a lot of Internet
resources so it's not gonna be a YouTube
video I mentioned YouTube like
podcasting and also we have a receptive
community now we can always our work and
and by by being concrete solid just like
skip the concreteness part of my and and
yeah well I mentioned earlier those like
computing people doing computing and
learning as a natural science we also
have role models on that like Josh
Tenenbaum or like Yoshi Benji a bit of
that and Leslie valiant nation and C
Lynch
those are like those are people who are
already preparing the the field for us
so so so we are lucky what what still
remains are the taboos there are still
some taboos among our peers machine
learning researcher is very senior very
respected ones and just like like just
like remind then house taboos slow down
progress so if we look at history parts
of the world was stuck when it was put
in a taboo on philosophy and natural
philosophy and the Islamic world for
example somehow emerged by just giving
some freedom to a bunch of blue sky
philosophers in Baghdad doing doing
philosophy Natural Sciences but then as
soon as the Islamic world started as
well taboo in them and like burning the
books and and and and and and doing
censorship its non-core
good stock and stopped making progress
and then we are like now it's just like
accelerate at the end of them so so that
boost slow down progress there are still
some taboos but I just like want to
highlight one thing people who are
making those taboos
there and trying without being malicious
sensor in the kind of AGI safety
research are not necessarily
bad don't necessarily have bad
intentions so just like I want to
conclude my this Moroccan program they
say like you have the stroke is bird
with a long beak we say that when the
stroke wants to kiss the baby the baby
loses the eye so I think some of our
peers and senior people just want us
good things like they would like they
wanted to secure careers published in
Europe's and ICMA papers which we should
do an issue
trying to do but out of good intentions
sometimes you can slow down progress by
putting some taboos I think we should
keep working hard on getting rid of
those taboos so that we make progress in
science challenges so I'm gonna kind of
focus on the reverse I didn't think
about advantages so like I made the
vagueness kept coming up it's true that
these problems are really vague but I
also think on the other hand because
they're big they're very interesting
there's a lot of conceptual work to be
done and it's not like an advisor can
just hand you a super concrete problem
but I almost think that's a good thing
because like everybody learns how to
solve problems but picking the problems
kind of the hard part and then I also
think that thinking about the long term
is a really good way to think about
problems so people often say you want to
create solutions that generalize across
tasks but I also think there's this sort
of generalization across time like as
there are more resources like systems
have more resources with the solutions
that we have now be as robust later on
and so I mean I personally am very
interested in both the short term and
long term both just because I think
short term is important and also because
I don't really trust things in the that
are for the long term but don't also
have some kind of short term payoff and
so I like to think of that
generalization is how I can make my
research more robust along that
timescale and then thirdly I think that
this community I actually like a lot
like often in fields where there are a
lot of competing paradigms people's egos
really get ruffled and so on I think
maybe because of founder effects of the
field like
an advantage of having a lot of people
who are just sort of like deferred to
the logic of the argument is that you
can have widely varying ideas and a lot
of speculation but still like coherent
discussions yeah great and I really want
to echo that point about creating
narratives and being able to tell
students about what feels good and what
is exciting about being in this area I
really think that we all want to think
about like how do we get the next group
of this panel up here so that there
aren't three people from Berkeley right
well how do we sort of make it so that
there's a much broader set of folks
feeding into this diverse and important
research area with that I want to open
up the panel to questions from the
audience
and in particular I'd like you to you
guys to focus on questions related to
technical research directions you think
are interesting for us and in particular
I want to call on students first because
this is the first panel this is student
panels so you guys get first first go
guys so I want to put forth my opinion
and see what you think about it I think
on the we should probably focus at least
a decent amount of resources on very
short timelines not because they
necessarily likely but because we don't
have enough information to completely
rule them out or rule them out like you
know with sufficiently high confidence
and I think in very short timelines
reward modeling is basically the best
approach because it really fits in well
with what everyone is doing in deep RL
right now and that's sort of the the
justification that I gave myself for
signing off on that paper that I did
with you on where we say like this is
the the highest impact or like the the
most important thing to be pursuing
right now I think it's just because you
know in the short timelines we have some
chance that this would work even though
I think it probably won't on there's
still some chance we kind of get lucky
and it turns out that AI is just learn
the right concepts and like don't you
know end up learning to be corrigible
and stuff like that is actually pretty
easy so I think
till we have maybe you know a whole like
team working on that which is sort of
what yawns trying to build I think
that's what I think I would tell
somebody who's like asking what should I
work on right now in alignment and I'm
curious if you guys would agree or if
not why I was using my natural
philosopher hat but actually in my day
time unlike a very engineering oriented
person and I think something this
community in particular has to do do
better at is that sometimes we have a
say eye safety problem X for which there
is a motivation and technical
formulation a and motivation and
technical formulation B a is short term
and B is long term always prefer a first
at least to convince other researchers
that it's not because like the solution
would work for both I'll just like give
two examples like poisoning we have it
today anti vaccine propaganda on social
media we have like yeah well poisoning
against democracy and I like safe
interoperability okay them to take safe
in terms of E is also post post problem
we have now with addiction to source of
addiction to social media is a safe
Finch of silly people we're like we're
not able to switch off Instagram so
always keep this and and the good news
is that those are areas on which I
personally with a bunch of friends can
have made significant technical progress
which is good to know and like to build
open so I think we have to keep an eye
on like both short term long term and
don't like always go back and forth
between the between the two yes so on
that note something I kind of forgot to
say is I think that's actually another
appealing property of looking at reward
modeling is that it is something that's
going to be useful for all sorts of
examples of neuro alignment and like
already people are really starting to
recognize much more broadly in the
machine learning community that we can
write down reward functions for really
basic tasks that we care about getting
our systems so if I can pick up on that
I so I think I agree I certainly agree
with some of the points that you're
making I think reward modeling is
important it's actually important not
only if you believe that there's a good
chance of a short timeline for extremely
advanced or AGI systems
but also to the extent that we are
producing increasingly capable AI
systems and systems that are in you know
interacting more and more with humans
even you know during the ramp by which
they start to increase the kinds of
tasks that we can assign to them I think
it is important that they are able to be
flexible in interpreting what it is that
the user wants and you know so anka has
been doing some research where you have
robots that are helping you in the home
there nothing close to super intelligent
but it is important to develop good
methods for these systems to you know to
work well to interface well with people
and to figure out what it is that people
are trying to tell them and a very
important thing that that comes up when
you're trying to do this kind of work is
that these systems need to be cognizant
of the fact that they probably don't
have a perfect model of what the humans
trying to do and this is I think it's
something I'd still going to be true
once we get to extremely high levels of
intelligence and so giving these systems
the ability to be humble when necessary
and to acknowledge that maybe they're
not quite sure what the human wants I
think it's going to be a very important
part of making these systems robust in
the not only in the near and medium term
but also in the long term um are you
putting a forward as something in
addition to reward modeling separate
from word reward modeling a reason why
reward modeling is important so what I
would say is that reward modeling needs
to have this humility component in it
and any sort of reward modeling that
would allow a system to ultimately
believe that it that now it has it now
it has a good model of the reward and I
can just go forward and essentially you
can all the human from now on I think
it's going to be a very dangerous system
you know it's going to lose of course
their courage ability property um I
don't know if you wanted to pitch in as
well as I don't want to answer so I
guess I think I've been seeing like one
of the things that this is thinking
about at this conference I've been
seeing like more parallels between that
and maybe like the AI services approach
and the iterated amplification approach
and like how they kind of fit into like
somewhat similar models with different
angles and thinking about that and I
think on some of those like shortened
relationship things I think like this
sort of like doing a reward modeling
better I think is like also like the
better more scalable solution to some of
the like near-term issues that people
are talking about today so I think if I
if I look at something like fairness I
think that like the the wrong approach
is to go and like write down what is the
one equation that like it defines what
fairness is and like let's make a system
that like does that and the right
approach is to like or like the approach
rather the approach that's going to like
scale better in the long term is like
figure out how to learn what fairness is
and how to make trade-offs in this like
complex space of like what that value is
please yeah and I think reward modeling
is really important but it seems to me
like a thing that we need to do to make
progress is to understand what like make
this reward more structured in some way
and I think maybe to draw maybe we need
to draw cognitive science insights more
or something but there's like this
extreme of building in the fairness
function to learning it completely and
there's somewhere in between and I can't
figure out how to get to that in between
yeah that I think yeah I'm curious what
you guys think about ethics review
boards or some analogous structure or
like what is wrong with ethics review
boards that we shouldn't have that may
be something like the standard section
of every paper that is ethics
acknowledgement section but I just think
I want something in machine learning to
make it very default and normal for
everybody to think about the ethical and
social implications of their research
and I'm curious what you guys think is
the best way to do that I think like the
the idea of making a sort of standard to
include information on like things like
ethics or I would I would think of like
scalability to like long term systems
just like being clear in your paper like
whether this algorithm like you have
thought about fairness or whether you're
just like you have not thought about
fairness at all or whether this is you
this algorithm you have like thought
about how it will scale to like
term systems or like you haven't thought
about this and so you're like you should
not apply this in a case where you're
like you know you're using like a vastly
more capable system like you had when
the paper was written I think given how
how internal review boards normally and
you know work in universities this seems
to be something that usually comes out
of the researchers themselves the
university sometimes you know can can
establish requirements for certain types
of research for example every time we do
an experiment where we have human
participants we have to go through the
university's internal review board and
there we do have to do all the
considerations about you know how is
this affecting the participant and also
what are the sort of positive
implications that we're hoping to get
out of the out of the research for a
general machine learning research I
think this is not usually the case and
if if it is to become the case I think
it probably at least in its initial
stages I would have to sort of come out
of the research community probably not
only this I certainly think that it
wouldn't hurt to have more to have it
become a more extended thing for 4ml
researchers and AI researchers in
general think about the technical
implications of their work and actually
and include it as part of their part of
their paper similar but I think I think
of this in a similar way to how I think
about the replicability and you know the
open sourcing of the code that you used
and giving all the all the meta you know
the hyper parameters for your
experiments I think it's it's a matter
of good scholarship almost and it would
be great if it became part of the of the
research culture absolutely alright I
think we're gonna have time for one more
question is that what you what you said
yeah are you concerned about external
pressures from academia and from
publication on your epidemics related to
research prioritization and if so what
can be done about it I have a negative
answer but maybe somebody wants to start
with a positive one I have a positive I
think that yeah the the the model of
peer reviewing and convincing your peer
like it remains one of like the worst
sorry the least bad past it's like it's
like yeah the least bad more than we
have so far is this I think we should
keep up like for now I think it's
important to go fight in the peer review
and convince your peers and go to ICML
and nerds and get your paper accepted
and present it etc it's still pragmatic
because this is how you'll get the
workforce joining you on that problem
this is at least how it works it worked
for us while we are like like almost
getting like starting out of the blue
are not part of the chai or M like older
like the famous AI technical safety
research groups like Dylan said that we
have to work more to make this panel
containing a more diverse set of people
not all like three from Barrie it's a
good thing like you were pioneers so why
not like you should you should you
should keep on being leading the
research that we request to answer max
is concerned that we have to like we
have to connect what we are saying now
to the action items I think one one of
the things that that talk to my heart a
lot is we have to as well as you say it
we have to get single groups less
over-represented here when you're
talking about Berkeley we have also to
make sure like in technical AI safety
there is a ratio of out of academia
researchers that you can't find and I
don't know chemical chemical reactions
like organic chemistry or or whatever
other field of research you would have a
high ratio of people from academia and I
think that's very healthy because it
allows a lot of freedom for example the
some things you can't really whatever
freedom you can get today and I'm aware
that some industrial groups give a lot
of freedom for to to their researchers
there are some things you just cannot do
if you're not in academia I personally
want to collaborate with social
scientists I'm trying to do that with
some colleague from school and I think
if it was from an industrial group you
just like not talk to me because like
yeah yeah you have data on people and
and what's what do you want to do with
this research with me and like what what
what I'm going to do for you so there
are some things you can't start outside
outside academia and we should make sure
that something like people say discern
for for AI research something on that
scale should should be created and
generously funded so that a generation
of like of people like us could go there
and play the multiplying role that that
academia plays because like this is
where you can multiply the workforce on
on interesting science not natural
science topics oh great so I absolutely
agree with what you're saying that was
gonna be my negative I'm so essentially
so no I'm not concerned about peer
review I believe very strongly in peer
review and I think that one of the worst
mistakes of this community could make
would be to turn its back on the rest of
the academic research in artificial
intelligence and machine learning and
automation science I think that we we
need to become ingrained and we know
well-established as part of the general
effort in the development of AI and I
think that the the right way to do this
is to convince our peers to to have a
you know an argued well argue debate
with them and you know I don't believe
in backdoors for this I think we should
we should we should enter the you know
the academic publications through the
front door of peer review as much as it
seems because whether or not your
research is short term or long term is
not based on the motivation section of
the paper it's not based on whether you
like cited boström in the introduction
and in fact I feel like just as a
computer
in paper it's kind of strange for you to
be like our goal is to get systems to
see it's also kind of strange to be like
when our goal is to have AGI and then
your paper is about safe exploration in
RL or something and so I think that
there's a lot that you can do about
training that makes the publication
process a lot easier also I think that
like I personally am skeptical of long
term solutions that don't have some sort
of short term output like not that like
right now there needs to be like a
solution to fairness that comes out of
your value alignment problem but it
should be like related like I don't
really quite believe that all of a
sudden superintelligence happens and
then there are these new problems that
are totally created I haven't yet come
up seen a problem that doesn't have some
sort of soft version so I think that
actually the peer review process is
almost like a regularizer to reality
yeah there are probably some ways in
which it could influence your research
direction a bit but I think they're a
bit overstated yeah I want to maybe just
maybe like slightly disagree and say
that like I feel I think we need spaces
where we can think about research
priorities in terms of API and have
people who are like supporting that and
to collaborate with that and I've been
lucky at Toronto to have like other
people who are like also like thinking
about thinking about these problems from
this perspective because I still think
that there there are problems that like
we might miss or we might approach in a
different way if we're thinking about
short-term things now I do think it's
important and in my work I'm trying to
do things that we can like test or like
do some version of and like try to like
get more information about today but I
yeah like I I yeah I don't know if you
would have generated the same kinds of
problems solutions that I'm like working
on if you would only been like thinking
about short-term things but like that
being said I think it's it is important
to like be able like in in in in you
know in most of the scenarios we would
think about like a GI going well at some
point
like a bottle there's the thing where we
need to like convince the research
community of our ideas and like that
needs to happen at some sage so we'd
like do you need to engage but I think
yeah we need spaces where we can say
like you know we're choosing research
priorities in terms of like AGI and have
people supporting us Smith I want to
invite you to respond to that quickly I
mean I don't disagree I think there's
it's sort of like there are different
processes for generating ideas and you
could start from the short-term and
think how can I make sure this works in
the long term you could start from the
long term and think how does this
conquer ties to the short term you could
think about both simultaneously and it's
probably good to have different
processes right in simplicity yeah yeah
yeah and in any case I think having some
form of quality control it's always a
good idea yes and nobody wants to be
doing research you know in a cellar
without talking to anyone that's
probably going to lead to diverging into
some yes less useful result great so
let's thank our panel for a very
interesting discussion
[Applause]
[Music]
you